I want to mention one thing everyone's
talking these days about celebrities and
their digital presence yes
all right well today my digital team
called me into their offices I thought
that was a little inappropriate
get down here shouldn't they come down
it they were like wait come down come
down so I went to their offices and they
gave me a rundown about my social
presence all right which was very useful
mostly good news this is all true check
it out I have almost nine million
followers on Twitter pretty cool
almost almost four million followers on
Google+
yeah over 2 million likes on Facebook
and yeah and almost 1 million
subscribers on YouTube so that's all
they explained to me they said that's
good news yeah that's good news but
there's one vital piece missing from the
Conan's social media Empire ladies and
gentlemen I have zero followers on
LinkedIn zero well guess what that's
about to change
now while other celebrities spend their
time trying to get more Twitter
followers and Facebook likes I've
decided I decided just a few hours ago
I'm going to conquer LinkedIn yes I am
yeah
[Applause]
that's right here's the only problem I
don't know what LinkedIn is what is it
I've never know I've never been on the
site I keep asking people nobody knows
nobody knows in spite of that I went
ahead and I created a LinkedIn profile
here's my header with the photo right
there chespin O'Brien CEO of Conan
overview current CEO Conan past
temporary consultant at the Tonight Show
with Conan O'Brien host at Late Night
with Conan O'Brien and I was a lighting
designer at Applebee's international for
a while education yes connections zero
connection yet not yet and here's some
more of my profile and things is really
gonna help me Conan O'Brien skills and
expertise talking pretending to listen
blaming my father and Microsoft Excel
Conan O'Brien's honors and awards Oscar
for Best Performance by an actress in a
supporting role for Michael Clayton yeah
that was
[Applause]
[Music]
so basically LinkedIn I'm talking to you
now all right
that's right LinkedIn I will not rest
until I become the number one
personality or influencer as you call it
on your site there's a term all the kids
are throwing around influencer anyway
now this is gonna be easy
here are the current top LinkedIn
influencers Richard Branson is number
one with over 2.5 million followers grew
Deepak Chopra has over 1.1 million
followers and President Obama the leader
of the free world nine hundred and sixty
eight thousand followers on LinkedIn so
here's my plan
LinkedIn make me an influencer and all
my fans out there or even if you're
watching and you're not a fan you've
wandered onto this channel by accident
you despise me but you have nothing
better to do
connect with me at wwe.com slash n slash
Conan O'Brien or visit team koco.com
slash LinkedIn together will complete
the conan social media empire and waste
america's time once again
[Applause]